so what is two factor authentication
factor one is what logging in with a
password and factor two is like have
another device
or another channel through which you can
confirm yeah that's me yes you know
usually this happens through some kind
of text
you know you get your one-time code from
bank of america or from google
and the better way to do it is spend 20
dollars buying yourself a fido key
on amazon that's a hardware device and
if you don't have that hardware device
with you
then you're not going to get in
and the whole goal is i mean basically
you know my first half of my decade at
the times was spent covering like the
cop beat it was like home depot got
breached news at 11 you know target
neiman marcus like who wasn't hacked
over the course of those five years
and a lot of those companies that got
hacked what did hackers take they took
the credentials they took the passwords
they can make a pretty penny selling
them on the dark web and people reuse
their passwords so you get one from you
know
god knows who i don't know
worst-case example actually lastpass but
you get one and then you go test it on
their email account and you go test it
on their brokerage account and you test
it on their cold storage account yeah
you know that's how it works but if you
have multi-factor authentication
then they can't get in because they
might have your password but they don't
have your phone they don't have your
fido key you know and and so you keep
them out
and you know i get a lot of alerts
that tell me someone is trying to get
into your instagram account or your
twitter account or your email account
and i don't worry because i use
multi-factor authentication they can try
all day
um okay i worry a little bit but you
know there it's
it's the simplest thing to do and we
don't even do it well there's an
interface aspect to it because it's
pretty annoying if it's implemented
poorly yeah so uh so actually bad
implementation of two-factor
authentication
not just bad but just
something that adds friction is a
security vulnerability i guess because
it's really annoying like uh i think mit
for a while had
two-factor authentication it was really
annoying i just it like though the time
the number of times it pings you
like uh
it re it asks to re-authenticate across
multiple sub-domains like it just feels
like a pain
um i don't know what the right balance
there yeah it feels like friction
in our frictionless society it feels
like friction it's annoying that's
security's biggest problem it's annoying
you know we need the steve jobs of
security to come along and we need to
make it painless and actually you know
on that point apple
has probably done more for security than
anyone else simply by introducing
biometric authentication first with the
fingerprint and then with face id it's
not perfect
but you know if you think just eight
years ago everyone was running around
with either no passcode an optional
passcode or four digit passcode on their
phone that anyone you know think of what
you can get when you get someone's
iphone if you steal someone's iphone and
you know props to them for introducing
the fingerprint and face id and again it
wasn't perfect but it was a huge step
forward now it's time to make another
huge step forward
um i want to see the password die i mean
it's gotten us as far as it was ever
going to get us and i hope whatever we
come up with next is not going to be
annoying it's going to be seamless when
i was at google that's what we worked on
is
and there's a lot of ways to call this
active authentication or passive
authentication so basically use
biometric data
not just like a fingerprint but
everything from your body to identify
who you are like movement patterns
so basically create a lot of layers of
protection where
it's very difficult to fake including um
like face unlock
checking that it's your actual face like
the liveness tests so like from video so
unlocking it with video yeah voice the
way you move the the the phone
um the way you take it out of the pocket
that kind of thing all of those factors
it's a really hard problem though yeah
and
ultimately
it's very difficult to beat the password
in terms of security
well there's a company that i actually
will call out and that's abnormal
security so
they work on email
attacks and
it was started by a couple guys who
were doing i think ad tech at twitter
so you know ad technology now like it's
a joke how much they know about us you
know you always hear the conspiracy
theories that you know you saw someone's
shoes and next thing you know it's on
your phone
it's amazing what they know about you
um
and they're basically taking that
and they're applying it to attacks so
they're saying okay you know if you're
this is what your email patterns are it
might be different for you and me
because we're emailing strangers all the
time um but for most people their email
patterns are pretty predictable
and if something strays from that
pattern
that's abnormal and they'll block it
they'll investigate it you know and and
that's great you know let's start using
that kind of targeted
ad technology
to protect people
and yeah i mean it's not going to get us
away from the password and using
multi-factor authentication but you know
the technology is out there
and we just have to figure out how to
use it in a really seamless way because
it doesn't matter if you have the
perfect security solution if no one uses
it i mean when i started at the times
when i was trying to be really good
about
protecting sources i was trying to use
pgp encryption and it's like it didn't
work you know the number of mistakes i
would probably make just trying to email
someone with pgp just wasn't worth it
um and then signal came along and and
signal made it a wicker you know they
made it a lot easier to send someone an
encrypted text message so we we we have
to start investing in
creative minds
um in good security design you know i
really think that's the hack that's
going to get us out of where we are
today
you